- Sashay and away sounds
like I don't know,
I'd rather shay, shay, stay.
(upbeat music)
- It's 2018 and RuPaul's
Drag Race is doing better
than ever and they're
pretty mainstream now.
A particular group of people who
is a little bit confused though
about the show is straight men.
They seem to know what it is,
but not really understand it.
So I invited four straight men
to come in here and make us believe
that they know RuPaul's Drag Race.
We're gonna show them a
few clips from the show
and then we're gonna
throw questions at them,
they can't say they don't know the answer.
So if they don't know
what I'm talking about
they have to make me
believe they know the show.
- Good luck and don't (beep) it up.
- Alright so the premise
of RuPaul's Drag Race
is um but..
- Ten or so drag queens come to see
who is the next drag superstar.
- So people do drag race right?
And they tryna win to become
part of RuPaul's crew.
- They are separate
challenges on each show
and you get judged by a panel of judges,
RuPaul being one of the judges
and then they have guest judges from
America's Next Top Model
and sometimes Ariana Grande.
- International competitors come in
and it's amazing, it's sorta like
a team battle at first and then it comes
down to sorta head to head by the end
and at the end somebody's gotta win.
- And RuPaul is the
ultimate drag queen, right?
She has a whole company of drag queens.
- They win a bunch of makeup and then,
and then they also get
like bragging rights.
- A battle of wit, visual
effects, makeup effects
where the most accurate
and poised look wins.
- A shanta Stay are you kidding me
I know what sashay away that's getting
kicked off the shows, that's like
you've been voted off of Survivor.
I don't know I don't watch Survivor okay,
all I watch is RuPaul's Drag Race.
- Sashay and away sounds like I don't know
I'd rather shay shay stay.
- I'd be asked to Shante and stay
until I was queen of the Drag Race.
- I would prefer to sashay way mainly
because I heard John Mulaney say it.
- Shante stay because sashay
away means you're eliminated.
(applause)
(curious music)
I think it's one maxi challenge
because if you win the maxi challenge
you get to choose someone to eliminate.
- The better is five mini challenges,
you gotta win, I think you
should, yeah the mini challenges
Are the uh even though the max,
you said the maxi challenge?
(beep)
- Winning one maxi challenge, if you're
gonna go and do something
you gotta be number one.
You gotta go and you gotta leave on top.
- Uh I mean, you gotta go big,
you gotta win the maxi challenges right?
You could win mini challenges all day long
but at the end of the
day, the maxi challenges
are really where you're gonna
get any sort of progress or power right?
(curious music)
- What would be my drag name?
La Negra Peligrosa, grrrrrrr,
you gotta add the grrrrrrr in there.
♪ Here we go again, again, again. ♪
- It would be Tikki Rico, Rikki-Tikki-Rico
(upbeat music)
♪ This star is... ♪
- I would be Big Cactus.
♪ 'cause I live for it, a year later ♪
- Gira Rafferty, 'cause like giraffe
It'd be Gira Rafferty, cause I'm tall.
♪ I, I, I, I can be crazy. ♪
- Getting to experience something
that's outside of your point of view,
is super important and I know
that I have gotten such a perspective
on this world that I
didn't even know existed.
- Exploring like the
emotions and the actual
personalities and the human beings
behind like drag culture,
I think is very important.
(upbeat music)